Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
KappaPogChamp, keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
I remember typing Dan's game, forehead SwiftRage, PJ Salt and Failfish.
Life was easy, spamming all the time, TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
KappaPogChamp, keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
Still hear his bark in the morning hour, he calls me, his doggy emote reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat, I get a feeling that I miss emotes from yesterday, yesterday.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Pog is PogChamp, Kappa is Kappa, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
KappaHands, Twitch emotes, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
You're not alone.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel...
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Twitch emotes from long ago...
Twitch emotes...